la présentation du projet d emmanuel
macron du président sortant peut pas
dire que ça fait un tabac ce que les
gens se disent marc hermant où est le
projet à 5 ans en matière de sécurité en
matière de pouvoir d'achat
rien ne changera rien ne changera pas
dans rien ne changera pendant cinq ans
donc on connaîtra pas on peut pas
connaître un meilleur quinquennat khl
dernier qui a été terrible et puis il y
a aussi un autre phénomène qui joue
beaucoup c'est que honnêtement voit bien
bout de cinq ans il ya plus d'idées il a
plus d'idées son seul projet aujourd'hui
c'est de rester au pouvoir qu'est-ce que
ça va changer qu'est ce que ça va
améliorer pour les français et là encore
une fois maquereau ou pécresse les gens
se tournent vers valérie pécresse mais
c'est ce que vous avez été surpris par
le montant que l'état français à payer
au cabinet de conseil tous ceux qui
conseillent les ministères en cas de
crise je pense à mckinsey capgemini ça
se monte à 1 milliard d'euros pour 2021
il a fallu débourser 4 millions d'euros
pour avoir la bonne idée de baisser de 5
euros les apl à mckinsey qui ne payent
pas d'impôts en france comme bien de
découvrir le gouvernement un pur
scandale un scandale d'état j'ai dénoncé
en découvrant ça il a fallu que ce soit
le sénat qui met sa à jour avec des
dirigeants qui doivent s'expliquer parce
que visiblement il aurait menti sous
serment devant les sénateurs mais
attendez gouvernement va pas s'en tirer
comme ça il faut des explications il ya
certainement des responsables être
capable de confier des marchés publics à
des entreprises qui ne règle pas
d'impôts dans notre pays je suis désolé
on est toujours sur le dos de toutes les
collectivités locales quelles qu'elles
soient pour faire bien attention à la
façon dont on passe des appels d'offres
et au sommet de l'état on s'en
dégagerait on s'en exonérer c'est ça
aussi qui donne ce sentiment que rien
n'est tenue qui a jamais de
responsabilités au sommet de l'état il
faut des explications
il faut que les ministres que l'appareil
d'état concernés impliqués puis aussi
autre chose va être aussi faire
confiance un certain nombre de
responsables publics plutôt que d'aller
chercher des responsables du privé au
lieu de casser le corps préfectoral
comme on est en train de le faire on
ferait mieux justement de faire
confiance à l'appareil d'état et puis
peut-être d'envisager aussi une autre
forme d'organisation du pays le pari abb
territoire de paris s'occupe bien de ce
qui est régalien de la préparation de
l'avenir et pour le reste qu'on fasse
confiance dans les territoires aux élus
ou par exemple à l'état dans les
territoires plutôt que ce soit dans
l'opacité d'un certain nombre de
ministères